hey everyone welcome to this week's
session
today's topic is react versus angular
in 2020 before we begin
i'd like to thank all our viewers for
actively participating in these sessions
and while still here subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from us
so what's in it for you we'll first get
familiar with both the programming
languages
by going through a quick introduction
then we will compare react and angular
focusing on their performance
after that we will discuss the learning
curve for learning both of these
frameworks
we'll also get to know about the
adoption of these frameworks
and their application in the field of
web development
after that we'll compare the community
support available for each framework
then we will dive into the industry
trends and job prospects
and in the end i'm going to tell you
which technology to choose
but i will give you enough food for
thought for you to choose the technology
that
suits you and your project best
so let me first give you an introduction
to react
now react is javascript library for ui
development
it is managed by facebook and has an
open source community of developers
the framework was introduced in may 2013
it is currently one of the most popular
front-end libraries
for web development moving on to angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework
for web development and mobile
development
it is typescript based and is managed by
google's angular team
and the angular developer community
launched in september 2016
angular also known as angular 2.0 is a
complete rewrite of angularjs
which was introduced in 2010. it
competes directly with react front-end
library
moving on let's go ahead and compare the
performance
now react's performance is greatly
improved with the introduction of the
virtual dom
and is generally better than that of
angular
react uses the concept of virtual dom
that puts less load on the browser
react was released with the usp of being
faster than other frameworks available
furthermore since the data binding
process is unidirectional
bindings are not assigned watchers as in
the case of angular
when it comes to angular it performs
worse especially in complex and dynamic
applications
the performance of angular apps is
negatively affected
by bi-directional data binding angular
uses traditional dom that updates the
whole web page
even if a single element is changed
however
the most recent update of angular has
greatly improved its performance
and it does not lose to react anymore
so moving ahead let me give you a brief
insight into the learning curve
react is a library and not a framework
it is quite simple to understand if
you're familiar with javascript
however it takes time to learn how to
set up a project properly
so you need to learn the redux library
which is used in more than half of
react applications for state management
react depends on other libraries to add
functionality
constant framework updates also require
additional effort from the developer
complex to understand some complicated
features are embedded into the framework
core which means that the developer
cannot avoid learning and using them
angular itself is a huge library so
initial learning effort is worth it
since you probably won't have to learn
other libraries like react
moving ahead let's look at the community
support
react framework is one of the most
popular javascript frameworks worldwide
it has larger community support and you
may face a lack of documentation at
times
the community support makes up for the
lack in documentation
when it comes to angular even though
angular was released before
its adoption is lesser when compared to
react
comparatively it has a smaller community
support
documentation is on point and definitely
better in the case of angular
also the community support has improved
over the few years
moving on let's look at adoption and
application
react was released in may 2013.
react is more popularly adopted by
developers due to its simplicity
it is actively used by companies like
facebook twitter
netflix airbnb and many others
now here new york times is one of the
many popular websites
built using react every new section
acts as a separate component so if any
one of the component updates
the entire web page doesn't have to
reload making the web app feel much
faster
and smoother this is just to give you a
brief example
when it comes to angular it was released
in october 2010.
even though it has improved now
developers used to ignore angular due to
its complexity at the time of its
release
angular is used by google apple nike
mcdonald's and other companies
now gmail is one of the many popular
websites built using angular
only the initial loading takes time but
after that
everything is so smooth because it is
pre-loaded onto the web browser
similarity of react and angular in the
last 5 years
we can clearly make out that react's
popularity is increasing over time
while angular's popularity is more of a
straight line
moving on to job trends a react
developer's average salary in the united
states is around 91 000 us dollars per
annum
in india the average salary of a
reactive lopper is around 7.35 lakhs per
annum
when it comes to angular an average
salary of an angular developer
in the us is around 73 000 us dollars
when it comes to india the average
salary is around 4.88 lakhs per annum
so in conclusion angular is a
full-fledged mobile and web development
framework
react is a library only for ui
development which can be turned into a
full-fledged solution with the help of
additional libraries
react seems simpler at first sight and
it takes lesser time to start working on
a react project
however that simplicity as the main
advantage of react is neutralized
because you have to learn to work
with additional frameworks and tools
anger itself
is more complex and takes quite some
time to master
yet it is a powerful tool that offers a
holistic web development experience
and once you learn how to work with it
you reap the fruits
now there is no better framework both
are updated continuously to keep up with
the competitor
for instance while react was believed to
win because of its virtual dom
angular equaled the score by
implementing change detection
in the end angular versus react is all a
matter of personal preference
a matter of skills and habits as a
beginner in programming
you would probably benefit more from
starting with react
as an experienced developer you just
keep working with what you know
better so with that i'd like to end this
session
i hope you liked it do you think we
missed out on anything important
let us know in the chat section below
thank you so much for watching
and thank you so much for tuning in
we're going to be back with more videos
soon
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here